hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and we finally
know every single Quirk that all 10
current and former one for all users had
possessed over the course of many
generations well we have nine full-time
users and one temporary user since the
final Quirk was just revealed recently I
thought that this would be the perfect
time to update all of our information
and explain all the users and all their
quirks right here in one place I will
also explain how the evolution of one
for all itself has completely changed
these quirks over time and made it
possible to use incredible combo super
moves so let's get into it you guys know
how this works if you enjoy our mha
videos and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment
right now it only takes you a second
it's really quick but it helps us out
with that YouTube algorithm and if
you're new to the channel or maybe you
just haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet do me a huge favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on on all
notifications it is a completely free
but very real way of directly supporting
the channel finally this video will
contain mha manga spoilers in terms of
the quirks their users and how the
quirks work I will try to avoid major
plot spoilers but the manga is far ahead
of the anime so you have been warned
first up we have the 9th and current one
for all user our protagonist izuku
midoriya also known as Deku deku's a
lifelong dream was to become a Great
Hero just like his Idol all might but
Deku was born quirkless in a world where
at least 80 percent of people are born
with quirks the fact that he didn't have
a quirk made it very difficult for Deku
to become a successful Pro Hero because
the other Heroes who had extremely
powerful quirks had a huge advantage
over him not to mention the fact that
the villains also have powerful quirks
so a quirkless hero would have a very
difficult time holding his Zone against
them now I remember when this series
began some people were hoping that Deku
wouldn't get a quirk and that he would
just use his intelligence and modern
technology to fight villains kind of
like Batman but unfortunately for Deku
he is not an eccentric billionaire so
becoming Batman wasn't really an option
everything changed for Deku after a
chance meeting with toshinoriagi whose
other Alias is the legendary Pro Hero
all might after seeing deku's courage
and commitment to becoming a hero
despite being born quirkless all might
decided to transfer his own Quirk one
for all to Deku one for all is an
extremely unique Quirk that can be
transferred from one person to another
and the transfer can happen only if the
current user willingly allows the new
user to consume some of their DNA in the
case of Deku all might had him consume a
strand of his hair and although this is
a little weird it also gave us a ton of
great memes when he first inherited The
Quirk Deku had a very hard time
controlling it and he would constantly
hurt himself every time he tried to use
it and I mean like he would seriously
hurt himself he would break a finger or
an arm and he would need serious medical
attention but thanks to some intense
training incredible dedication and
top-tier mentorship from both all might
and Gran Torino Deku eventually learned
to control how much of one for all's
power he uses when he attacks and so he
was able to use the Quirk effectively
without constantly injuring himself and
once Deku actually learned to use his
quirk in a way that allows him to stay
out of the hospital he was able to
practice with it and discover its true
potential and its insane versatility
since we already talked a bit about
toshinoriyagi also known as the symbol
of peace all might we might as well
focus on him next much like Deku almight
was born without a quirk and this was
part of the reason why all might
instantly connected with Deku and was
able to relate to him on a personal
level despite being born quirkless all
might inherited one for all from his
master Nana shimura and he was a user
one for all for 40 years this is
significantly longer than any other user
in one for all's history and the reason
for this is revealed later on in the
story during his time as the wielder of
one for all all might became a legendary
hero and the symbol of peace and he was
actually able to defeat the most
notorious villain in the history of
Japan all for one on two separate
occasions all for one has been the
greatest Nemesis of every single one for
all user ever since the Quirk was first
created and yet no user was ever able to
defeat him before all might needless to
say all might's tenure as the user won
for all was historic in many ways by
finally defeating all for one and
forcing the archman villain into hiding
all might brought an end to the chaos
caused by all for one's villainous
schemes and ushered in an era of Peace
because of this all might literally
became the symbol of peace the man who
brought the entire hero Society together
and made everyone feel safe in that
sense all might really blazed the trail
for the next generation of Heroes
including of course Deku but also bakugo
stars and stripes and many others all
might had a very strong and resilient
body so he was able to adapt to one for
all very quickly and he didn't have to
struggle as much as Deku in order to
master the quirk in fact all might was
so good at using one for all that he
became the strongest hero in history
back when he was in his prime but by the
time that all might met Deku he was
nowhere near his prime he had been
permanently injured in a previous battle
against all for one which severely
limited his ability use one for all his
body simply could not handle using the
Quirk for more than a few hours a day
and at that point it became clear that
all might had to find a successor after
transferring The Quirk to Deku all might
still had some remaining Embers of one
for all which he was able to call upon
in battle but eventually those Embers
were extinguished and he became
effectively quirkless once again as a
result all might retired from being a
Pro Hero and his main job now is to
Mentor his successor Deku he's basically
Alfred now and he does drive a sick
Batmobile next up is the seventh one for
all user and all might's former Master
Nana shimura Nana had a close personal
and professional relationship with Gran
Torino and she is also the grandmother
of tomurashigaraki whose birth name is
tenko shimura when he was still very
young Nana gave up her son kotaroshimura
and had him raised with a fast Foster
family in order to protect him from all
for one Nana did this after all for one
had already killed her husband and so
Nana knew that her war against all for
one was putting her son in direct danger
she didn't give up her son because she
didn't want him she gave him up because
she felt that this was the only way to
save his life as a user of one for all
she was a constant Target for all for
one and the villains and so was everyone
who was close to her so for that reason
she decided to give up her son in order
to take him out of Harm's Way
nevertheless Nana's son kotaro felt hurt
and rejected by his mother after she
gave him up to a foster family he didn't
see this as her making a massive
sacrifice in order to protect him he saw
it as her choosing her Pro Hero career
over him after all if Nana had just
retired from being a Pro Hero then she
would no longer be a target for all for
one and the two of them could have lived
happily as a family as a result kotaro
began to despise both Heroes and the
hero profession and when he grew up and
had a family of his own he allowed this
hatred to affect the way that he treated
his son tanko little tenko shimura
dreamed of one day becoming a Pro Hero
but every time he brought that up in
front of his father he was faced with
criticism and outright abuse from kotaro
ironically Nana abandoned her son in
order to protect him from dangerous
villains but kotaro's abandonment issues
which led to his hatred of Heroes
ultimately played a pivotal role in
creating the monster that we know today
as tomurashigaraki unlike Deku and
almight Nana wasn't born quirkless
before inheriting one for all she
possessed her own Quirk called float
which allowed her to levitate through
the air now just levitating through the
air on its own isn't the most useful
quirk in battle floating around like a
balloon or something is not not the same
as rapidly flying through the air to any
destination of your choosing however
when combined with one for all float
becomes a much more useful and Powerful
quirks that is because the stockpiled
energy from one for all can be used to
propel someone who is using float to the
exact location that they want to go
which essentially allows them to fly at
Great speeds thanks to one for all float
goes from being a floating Quirk to an
overpowered flying Quirk and once he
unlocks it Deku is able to make great
use of it both in terms of his mobility
and in terms of his offensive capability
Nana shimura was eventually killed by
all for one but as I said earlier she
was able to pass the one for all Quirk
onto all might before that happened and
that is actually similar to the way in
which she first received the one for all
Quirk from the sixth user and and so now
let's talk about the sixth user One for
All N spelled yen is a relatively short
man with dark hair and a high collared
dressing style that is reminiscent of
best genist as far as we know right now
there is no direct connection between
best genus and N so these similarities
could be just a coincidence Anne's
original Quirk is called Smoke screen
and it allows its user to generate smoke
and severely reduce his opponent's
visibility on the battlefield the smoke
can be spread over a very large area
meaning that the user can potentially
obscure visibility throughout an entire
Battlefield which can certainly make
things a lot harder for the user's
opponent or opponents but and readily
acknowledges that his Quirk is not
particularly strong and it has no
offensive capabilities its Effectiveness
can also be limited by weather such as
when it rains and if the user isn't
careful he could end up producing his
own visibility along with his opponents
smokescreen is by no means a super Quirk
on its own but when used in combination
with one for all and it's other quirks
it can be a very useful tool in deku's
Arsenal personally I like the fact that
someone for all users like Anne didn't
have an overpowered Quirk of their own
before inheriting one for all the person
with the strongest Quirk will not
necessarily be the best candidate for
inheriting one for all so it makes sense
that some users will have strong quirks
others will have weaker quirks and
others still will be quirkless all for
one tried to steal one for all from n on
two separate occasions and he failed
both times and became the sixth user of
one for all when he consumed the blood
of the fifth user daigorobanjo right
before he himself died at the hands of
all for one Speaking of which the fifth
user daigorobanjo was an eccentric and
funktastic pro hero whose official hero
name was Lariat banjo's appearances
sometimes compared to the character
Hellboy and since we know that horikoshi
is a massive fan of Western Comics it is
likely that Hellboy influenced bonjo's
design just like n banjo stopped all for
one from stealing one for all on at
least two separate occasions and he was
well known for being a highly energetic
hero with Incredible willpower and a
powerful Quirk he was also a muscular
stylish and super funky dude and his
original Quirk black whip was the first
new Quirk that Deku unlocked as part of
one for all's Awakening black whip
allows its user to generate black
tendrils from his body and use these
tendrils to either attack an opponent
restrain an opponent or increase the
versatility of the user's own movements
black whip is an extremely useful Quirk
and it appears to be powered by strong
emotions such as anger this means that
the angrier the user becomes while still
maintaining control of his senses the
stronger the Quirk will become black
whip can also also be combined with
other quirks in extremely effective ways
such as when Deku combines black whip
with fajin to create a new super move
called black chain aside from one for
all itself black whip is one of the
linchpins of deku's power and its
versatility allows Deku to combine it
with other quirks in extremely effective
ways as I mentioned earlier banjo was
killed by all for one but just before
dying he was able to pass one for all
onto end so now let's talk about the
person from whom banjo had inherited one
for all in the first place which is the
fourth user of one for all hikage
shinomori hikage has two lines that
resemble scars running down the left
side of his face and unlike the other
one for all users the fourth user chose
to avoid confronting all for one head on
instead he lived on a Zone in the
wilderness like a Hermit because he
didn't want all for one to find him and
try to steal one for all from him he
knew that he couldn't defeat All For One
on his own so he dedicated his life to
training and strengthening the one for
all quirk in order to make it stronger
since one for all is a stockpiling Quirk
it will become stronger over time so
hikake was betting on the future
generation and he was hoping that his
eventual successor would be strong
enough to defeat All For One even if he
himself would never be hika has spent 18
years cultivating and strengthening the
one for all Quirk but his body
eventually began to break down as a
result of actively using one for all for
so many years the scars on his face
appear to have been caused by the
physical breakdown which he experienced
and although he was never caught or
killed by all for one in the end hikake
died of old age when he was only 40
years old although not before passing
one for all on to daigorobanjo it was
later revealed that all users who
already had a quirk before inheriting
one for all would experience a similar
physical breakdown if they lived long
enough that's because trying to juggle
both one for all and another separate
Quirk is simply too much for the human
body to handle and so as it turns out
the ideal one for all user is one who
started out quirkless like all might and
Deku they do not experience the same
type of physical breakdown no matter how
many years they live with one for all
which is why all might was able to use
it for 40 years without dying the
original Quirk that hikage was born with
is called danger sense and it allows its
user to instantly identify imminent
threats in the surrounding area it's
essentially a spidey sense and just like
smokescreen it can be very useful in
battle but it doesn't necessarily have
offensive capabilities on its own once
Deku unlocks the ability to use the
Quirk he describes it as a sharp
stabbing sensation in his head which
alerts him that danger is coming the The
Quirk can sense both imminent physical
threats and negative human intentions
and emotions however The Quirk does not
react when someone attacks Deku without
malicious intent so danger sense has one
fatal weakness and it's called yandere
girls if I yawned at a girl like toga
attacks Deku out of affection rather
than out of ill intent danger sense will
not activate again this is not a quirk
that will allow you to defeat an
opponent on its own but in combination
with the other one for all quirks it is
extremely useful in battle for example
you can use smoke screen as much as you
want and still know where your opponent
is because of danger sense now let's
talk about the third one for all user
whose name has still not been revealed
he was a prominent member of the
resistance movement that fought against
all for one when he was first
establishing himself as the villain
Overlord of Japan all along with the
second one for all user he identified
where all for one's younger brother
yoichi was being held and he broke into
the compound with the intention of
assassinating him but after realizing
that over one's brother was opposed to
what all Throne was doing and was being
held prisoner for that very reason the
second and third user decided to rescue
yoichi yoichi would eventually be killed
by his own brother all for one but
before he died he transferred one for
all to the second one for all user the
second one for all users soon met the
same fate but not before transferring to
court to the third one for all user that
process was then repeated again when the
third user transferred one for all to
hikage and so on the third user's
original Quirk is called vajin this
Quirk allows its user to build up
kinetic energy in their body by
repeating regular movements and this
energy can then be stored up and used
later when enough energy is built up the
user can use it to release superhuman
bursts of strength and speed the user
has the ability to control how much
energy is being released at what time so
it doesn't all need to be released at
once it can be released in multiple
bursts faujian was a much weaker Quirk
before the third user inherited one for
all but because both fajin and one for
all are stockpiling quirks the power of
fajin increases drastically when it is
coupled with the Power of One for All
For example when he unlocks the ability
to use it Deku is able to combine farjin
with 45 percent of one for all's power
and black whip to achieve levels of
strength and speed that are on par with
using 100 percent of one for all if it
were being used on its own with the
added benefit that deku's body doesn't
have to suffer the physical consequences
of outright using 100 percent one for
all the name fajin was inspired by a
term in Chinese martial arts that refers
to discharging power in a sudden and
explosive manner then we have the second
one for all user whose Quirk was the
last one to be revealed in chapter
368 of the story the second user was a
man with spiky hair and an x-shaped scar
across his face who kinda looks like an
adult bakugou back when he was alive he
used to wear a pair of gauntlets on his
arms as part of his costume and he was
also present at yoichi's rescue along
with the third user the second user is
believed to have been the leader of the
resistance movement that tried to stop
all for one's takeover of Japan and
because he believed that the goal of
stopping all for one was incredibly
important for the entire world he was
willing to do whatever it takes to get
the job done including potentially
killing people who gone in his way after
all at first he was planning to
assassinate yoichi just because yoichi
was close to all for one but he
eventually changed his mind when he
realized that the resistance in yoichi
share the same goal due to the extremely
hard times that he lived in hard times
that required hard decisions the second
user along with the third user initially
refused to accept Deku as a worthy one
for all successor they felt that deku's
outlook on life was too naive and
optimistic and that he wasn't willing to
get his hands dirty when the situation
required it which could be a big problem
during an intense high-stakes battle
they felt that Deku simply didn't have
it in him to kill anyone not even a
dangerous villain and so he didn't have
what it takes to be a true successor for
the one for all Quirk nevertheless the
second and third users eventually
changed their opinions of Deku after
yoichi convinced them to trust him and
after seeing some of deku's recent
actions the second user has an extremely
powerful Quirk and it is much more
powerful now that it has been combined
with one for all in fact this Quirk is
so powerful that it can be very
dangerous and the second user tells Deku
to only use it as a last resort the
quirk's name is transmission sometimes
translated as gear shift and it allows
its user to shift the speed of anything
he touches the user can use it on
himself to make his own movements much
faster and he can also use it to shift
the speed of his opponent after making
direct contact with him the first time
we see Deku using the Quirk he
demonstrates its incredible power by
increasing his own speed then punching
shigaraki upward and increasing the
villain speed then Switching gears to
increase his own speed even further he
goes into second gear and punches
shiraki again even faster then he goes
into third gear and punches him again
then he goes into Top Gear and punches
him yet again at one point shigraki and
Deku begin to move at such incredible
speed that Meteo notices that the sound
of deku's punches is actually delayed
Deku eventually catches up to the
rapidly moving she got and even
overtakes him using the transmission
quirk's ultimate gear overdrive Deku
then punches down on shigaraki with a
brutal Detroit smash the power of deku's
downward punch smashes against all of
that upward momentum that shigaraki's
body had built up after being punched
multiple times and this creates an
absolutely devastating attack and in
fact by using the transmission quirk in
combination with Detroit's match the
power of this Detroit smash goes from
100 to 120 percent making it even
stronger than the legendary 100 percent
one for all just like other quirks that
are now part of one for all the second
user's Quirk used to be much weaker than
it is today in fact its power now is
practically unrecognizable all for one
remembers that back when the second user
was still alive his Quirk was just a
pathetic little peashooter Quirk that
was only able to control the speed of
small objects the second user could
control small objects and launch them at
his opponents but that was pretty much
it back then the second user presented
absolutely no challenge to all for one
and all for one eliminated him as a
threat without much trouble but now that
transmission is being used by Deku
things are very different one for all is
of course a stockpiling Quirk and it has
been stockpiling power for many decades
and so as one for all became stronger so
did all of the quirks that had been
residing inside of it including
transmission and not only is
transmission itself stronger but Deku is
also able to use combo quirks such as
using transmission and one for all at
the same time or transmission and
fogging at the same time
Etc the end result of all of this is
something completely different from what
all for one remembers the raw stockpiled
power of one for all combining with
transmission packs enough power
Bend even the laws of physics the second
user explains that transmission allows
him to change his speed while ignoring
inertia meaning that the speed of deku's
movements is literally beyond the laws
of physics he is changing the speed of
things on a cellular level and so our
normal understanding of things like
inertia momentum acceleration and
deceleration simply don't apply anymore
it goes without saying that at this
point in time transmission is an
absolutely overpowered Quirk and it
provides an amazing addition to deku's
Quirk roster and finally let's talk
about the very first user one for all
the younger brother of all for one
yoichi shigaraki yoichi and his older
brother were born many generations ago
at a time when quirks were First
beginning to manifest in people
initially the two brothers seem to have
a good relationship and they enjoyed
reading superhero comics together they
were especially fans of a comic called
Captain Hero and while yoichi related to
the hero of the story Captain Hero his
older brother was actually a fan of the
hero's primary Nemesis the Demon Lord
eventually the sudden appearance of
quirks threw Society into chaos as
people simply didn't know how to deal
with them and at this point it became
evident that the two brothers held
Completely Different World Views all for
one wanted to exploit the chaos in order
to seize power and create a new world in
his own image meanwhile yuichi believed
that heroic individuals with quirks
should use their power to restore order
and justice but all for one was born
with an incredibly powerful Quirk so he
had a clear Edge over his younger
brother in fact while all for one had
one of the strongest quirks in history
at first everyone believed that yoichi
was born quirkless because his Quirk
never manifested in any noticeable way
even when he was believed to be
quirkless yoichi tried to oppose the
actions of his older brother because he
believed that what all for one was doing
was fundamentally wrong but of course
yoichi wasn't strong enough to threaten
all for one in any way and because
yoichi was the only family that all for
one had and because he posed no threat
to him the villain didn't outright kill
his brother instead he kept him as a
prisoner in the hopes that he could one
day convince his brother to see things
his way all for one also felt bad that
his little brother was born quirkless
and he felt that maybe yoichi would
understand all for one's perspective if
he also had a strong Quirk like his
older brother so the older brother
decided to give the younger brother a
stockpiling Quirk that he had obtained
using the powers of the all for one
where nevertheless it turned out that
all for one's brother did actually have
a quirk but this quirk's only ability
was to transfer itself onto another user
since this was literally all that ever
ever did it was basically useless and it
never manifested in any way but once the
stockpiling Quirk was transferred into
yoichi by All For One it merged with the
transferring Quirk and out of these two
completely different quirks The Quirk we
know today as one for all was born
yoichi was eventually freed from his
captivity by the two members of the
resistance movement that we had talked
about earlier these are the two guys who
would eventually become the second and
third users of one for all yoichi
clearly had a strong sense of right and
wrong and even though all for one was
his own brother once he was freed he
worked tirelessly to bring his brother
down unfortunately yoichi was simply too
weak to actually threaten all for one
and he is presumed to have lost his life
in a fight against all for one and his
minions but before he died yoichi did
manage to transfer his Quirk to a
successor that successor was of course
the second one for all user yoichi
believed that even if he himself was
unable to stop all for one one day as
one for all becomes stronger a successor
will emerge who will finally be strong
enough to defeat All For One and as we
know now yoichi was right because all
might did eventually defeat all for one
and all might successor Deku is in the
process of becoming even stronger than
all might and although we just covered
all the permanent full-time one for all
users we do have to also quickly talk
about the 10th user who only used one
for all temporarily but he did indeed
use it I am talking about katsuki
bakugou who uses one for all alongside
Deku during their battle against the
villain 9 in the my hero Academia Heroes
Rising movie when Deku realizes that he
won't be able to defeat 9 on his own he
gives some of his blood to bakugou
thereby transferring his DNA onto his
friend this allows bakugou to use one
for all and he instantly proves to be
extremely skilled using it probably
probably because he has been watching
Deku so closely for such a long time he
is able to use one for all full cowl 100
percent without doing serious damage to
his body and he is also able to use one
for all to make his own Quirk explosion
even stronger than before as the name
suggests bakugou's Quirk allows him to
create explosions and thanks to one for
all his explosions became stronger and
their temperature increased greatly at
the end of the fight bakugou loses his
ability to use one for all while Deku
still retains it this suggests that Deku
didn't fully transfer The Quirk to
bakugou from himself but rather did he
just let him borrow its powers
temporarily since we know that the Quirk
one for all is sentient it is possible
that the vestiges made sure that Deku
wouldn't lose the Quirk even after
allowing bakugou to borrow some of its
power because of course they believe
that Deku is the one who is destined to
unlock the full potential of one for all
so they didn't want Baku to actually
inherit Quirk from Deku they just
allowed him to borrow some of its power
and in the end they made sure that the
Quirk remained inside deku's body now
there is a big debate about whether or
not the movies are Canon because they
are a bit over the top and they are not
directly relevant to the plot of the
main series some people swear that they
are indeed Canon While others swear that
they are not there is no direct
indication that the movies are not canon
and in fact some characters from the
movies were later mentioned in the
official manga or teased in silhouette
form so we have to treat the movies as
at least somewhat relevant to the main
story one for all also has another
interesting property that has been
extremely useful to its users in the
ongoing multi-generational fight against
all for one I mentioned this a bit
earlier but all for one's primary
ability is of course to steal the quirks
of others but one for all cannot be
transferred from its current user to
another user without the consent or of
the current user essentially one for all
cannot be taken away unless the user
wills it which is why all for one has
not been able to steal it for all these
years even though he has definitely been
trying this is also why one for all has
been the single most effective weapon
against all for one that said though all
for one has been actively looking for a
way to steal one for all four
generations and he now believes that
using tomura shigaraki's body may allow
him to finally steal it that is because
shigaraki's hatred and willpower just
may be strong enough to overcome one for
all and its vestiges and speaking of the
vestiges even though yoichi sacrificed
his life in the fight against all for
one a part of him still lives on as a
Vestige inside of one for all and along
with all the other former users he is
still guiding the current user of one
for all in their common quest to finally
defeat All For One and there is
everything we know so far about all nine
one for all users and their quirks how
do you feel about the final Quirk reveal
and who is your favorite one for all
user which of their quirks do you think
would be most useful to have in real
life don't forget to share your feedback
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this mha video and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like it only takes a second but it helps
me out a lot and if you haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications you really
do have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting the bell and then
selecting the option that says all if
you don't go through all of those steps
you're still gonna miss a ton of our
videos even if you are subscribed that's
just how YouTube works you can also hit
me up on Twitter and Instagram at
animeoproar as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya Space Cowboys